AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRAT PARADE OF
IDIOCY LAST NIGHT WAS SO
SPECTACULAR, WE FELT COMPELLED
TO BRING BACK THE INGRAHAM
AWARDS.
OKAY, JOINING ME TO PRESENT
THESE PRESTIGIOUS AWARDS IN
COMMENT, THE SENIOR ADVISOR TO
THE TRUMP 2020 CAMPAIGN.
SHE'S LIVE FROM CPAC WEST IN
RENO, NEVADA, ALSO HERE, TOM
BEVIN, CO-FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
GREAT TO SEE YOU ON A FRIDAY
NIGHT.
FIRST UP, OKAY, WE'RE CALLING
THIS IS ANNIE GRAB YOUR GUN
AWARD.
AND IT GOES TO, BETO OROURKE.
OKAY, WELL, APPARENTLY HE CAN'T
STAND A MAN WITH A GUN.
>> ARE YOU PROPOSING TAKING WAY
THEIR GUNS, AND HOW WOULD THIS
WORK?
>> I AM.
IF IT'S A WEAPON THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO KILL PEOPLE.
HELL YES, WE'RE GOING TAKE YOUR
AR-15, YOUR AK-47.
>> Laura: MERCEDES BETO LEANED
INTO THE STEREOTYPE UNVEILING
THE NEW SLOGAN, "BAY TOE HAS A
BAN FOR THAT."
HE UNVEILED THAT.
IS THIS GOING TO WIN?
>> IT WON'T WIN STATES LIKE
TEXAS, FOR EXAMPLE.
AND EVEN TODAY, SPEAKING TO
SEVERAL OF THE AUDIENCE MEMBERS
IN NEVADA, YOU KNOW, THEY HAD A
VERY SERIOUS DISCUSSION ON THE
2nd AMENDMENT AND THE FACT THAT
ESPECIALLY IN THE RURAL COUNTIES
OF NEVADA AND CERTAIN STATES
LIKE NEW MEXICO, THAT THEY'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS BEING VIOLATED.
AGAIN, THERE IS -- THERE IS THIS
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL
WITH GUN VIOLENCE, ABSOLUTELY.
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS ADDRESSED
THIS ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
FIGURING OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
MORE EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT TAKING AWAY GUNS FROM
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
IT ABSOLUTELY VIOLATES OUR 2nd
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
AND IT'S INCREDIBLY TROUBLING.
WHILE THE BASE -- THE LIBERAL
BASE GETS EXCITED ABOUT THIS AND
BETO IS TRYING TO GAIN POINTS ON
THE LIBERAL SIDE, I THINK WHEN
YOU LOOK AT COMMON SENSE
AMERICANS ARE SAYING, WAIT A
SECOND, HE'S GOING WAY TOO FAR.
>> Laura: TOM, QUICKLY ON THIS,
I'M GOING TO GET TO THE NEXT
AWARD, LAST YEAR, YEAR BEFORE
LAST, HE GAVE A RADIO INTERVIEW
WHERE HE BASICALLY CONTRADICTED
EVERYTHING HE'S SAYING NOW.
SO I GUESS WE CAN SAY IN LIBERAL
LAND, HE'S EVOLVED ON THIS
ISSUE.
BUT WHAT A WILD MESSAGE FROM
SOMEONE FROM TEXAS.
ALL OF THE STUFF ON THE INTERNET
WAS TODAY YOU COME AND TRY TO
TAKE MY AR-15s, PEOPLE WEREN'T
HAVING ANY OF THIS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
BETO PROBABLY NOT GOING TO WIN
THE NOMINATION BUT CHALLENGING
JOHN CORNYN FROM TEXAS.
IF REPUBLICANS HAD THE SLIGHTEST
WORRY ABOUT BETO RUNNING FOR
SENATE IN TEXAS, THEY'RE NOT
WORRIED ANYMORE, HE'S
UNELECTABLE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS
>> Laura: THE BEST SCHOOLING OF
THE RHODES SCHOLAR GOES TO
JULIAN CASTRO.
MAYOR PETE WAS A LITTLE SHELL
SHOCKED HERE.
>> THIS REMINDS EVERYBODY ABOUT
WHAT THEY CANNOT STAND ABOUT
WASHINGTON, SCORING POINTS
AGAINST EACH OTHER, POKING AT
EACH OTHER, AND TELLING EACH
OTHER THAT YOUR PLAN, MY PLAN,
WE ALL --
>> IT'S THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
ELECTION.
IT'S CALLED AN ELECTION.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
IT'S AN ELECTION.
>> Laura: MERCEDES, MAYOR PETE
LOOKED LIKE HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FILMING A GOT MILK AD OR
SOMETHING.
HE WAS A SCHOOL BOY OR
HE WAS MEAN.
I'M A BIG FAN OF CASTRO, BUT
THAT WAS A GOOD MOMENT.
>> THE EXCHANGE WAS INTENSE.
FOR PETE TO GET INTENSE, IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN TOO OFTEN.
HE MUMBLED HIS WAY THROUGH.
THE SECOND-YEAR CANDIDATES
AREN'T REALLY BREAKING THROUGH.
AND PETE HASN'T REALLY OFFERED A
VISION, MANY OF THESE DEMOCRATS,
THEY HAVEN'T OFFERED A VISION OF
HOW THEY WANT TO MOVE FORWARD
AND HELP AMERICA GROW,
ESPECIALLY FROM THE TERMS OF
WHAT YOU SAID EARLIER, FROM AN
ECONOMIC STANDPOINT.
SO I THOUGHT THE EXCHANGE WAS
BIZARRE BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM.
AND PETE'S TRYING TO TAKE THE
UPPER HAND ON THIS.
BUT I THINK IT JUST FELL FLAT.
>> Laura: THIS IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE AWARDS.
IT'S A HIGH BAR.
ALL RIGHT, TOM, THE MOST LIKELY
TO CONDUCT THE BOSTON
PHILHARMONIC AWARD GOES TO --
BERNIE SANDERS.
ALL RIGHT, BERNIE SANDERS LOOKED
LIKE LEONARD BERNSTEIN UP THERE.
WATCH.
>> SPENDING TWICE AS MUCH PER
CAPITA ON HEALTH CARE AS THE
CANADIANS OR ANY OTHER MAJOR
COUNTRY ON EARTH.
>> IT'S AMERICA.
>> BUT AMERICANS DON'T WANT TO
PAY TWICE AS MUCH AS OTHER
COUNTRIES.
>> Laura: TOM, HE DOES LIKE TO
DO THIS A LOT AND -- WE'RE
HAVING FUN WITH BERNIE.
BUT DID HE HIT HIS PEAK IN 2016?
HE'S BEEN REPLACED IN THE
PROGRESSIVE LANE, HASN'T HE?
HE'S BEEN EDGED OUT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, BERNIE, THIS IS THE SORT
OF -- BERNIE 2.0, IT'S JUST A
CRANKIER, LOUDER VERSION.
HE SEEMS TO BE ANGRY AND
SHOUTING ALL THE TIME.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT MODELS NOW.
NEWER MODELS, FRESHER MODELS,
MORE EXCITING MODELS.
BERNIE IS STAYING TRUE TO
HIMSELF FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH.
BUT IT'S THE SAME STORY EVERY
TIME HE STEPS ON THE DEBATE
STAGE.
>> MERCEDES, HE DOES KIND OF
LOOK ANGRY ALL THE TIME.
PEOPLE SAY TRUMP'S ANGRY.
HE'S IN A GOOD MOOD.
HE FIGHTS BACK WHEN HE'S HIT.
BUT HE'S HAVING FUN.
BUT HE'S JUST -- HE'S THE "GET
OFF MY LAWN" GUY.
BERNIE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A GREAT
SENSE OF HUMOR TOO.
THAT'S ONE OF THE BEST PARTS
ABOUT HIM.
FOR BERNIE, HIS BIGGEST
CHALLENGE, OBVIOUSLY, IS THE
POLICIES REALLY, HE HAS DEFINED
THAT SOCIALIST BRANCH OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND THERE'S THE POPULARITY
THAT'S GROWN AROUND HIM AND
ELIZABETH WARREN AS WE KNOW
THEY'RE SPLITTING THAT VOTE
RIGHT NOW.
BUT HE'S TAKEN THE PARTY TO SUCH
AN EXTREME.
AND VERY MUCH OPENLY ADMITTING
HE WANTS TO RAISE TAXES ON THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
>> YEAH.
>> EVERYBODY IS SAYING THAT NOW.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
BUT NOW HE'S BEEN ONE ON THE
LEADS ON THIS.
HE'S ONE OF THE LEADERS ON
PUSHING THE MIDDLE CLASS.
>> Laura: AS TOM SAID, THERE ARE
NEW AND IMPROVED MODELS NOW.
ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
NEXT ONE.
FOR ONE OF OUR MOST COVETED
INGRAHAM AWARDS, THE AWARD FOR
THE BEST OPRAH GIVEWAY MOMENT.
>> YOU GET A CAR.
>> Laura: THE AWARD GOES TO
ANDREW YANG.
>> MY CAMPAIGN WILL NOW GIVE A
FREEDOM DIVIDEND OF $1,000 A
MONTH FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR TO TEN
AMERICAN FAMILIES, SOMEONE
WATCHING THIS AT HOME RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: HANDOUTS ARE PRETTY
POPULAR FOR THE VOTERS.
I THINK HE WON A DRUDGE POLL.
WHAT ABOUT THIS ONE?
IS THERE ENOUGH CASH TO BUY THE
ELECTORATE.
>> YEAH, THIS ONE -- HE'S
PUSHING THE UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME, THAT'S ONE OF THE
PRIMARY PLANKS OF HIS PLATFORM.
BUT THIS GOT PANNED EVEN BY
FELLOW DEMOCRATS.
THEY ALL KIND OF -- EVEN THE
ONES ON THE STAGE WERE GIGGLING
AND LAUGHING ABOUT IT.
IT DIDN'T GO OVER WELL AMONG
EVEN LEFT WING FOLKS ON TWITTER.
THIS WAS A FAIL ON ANDREW YANG'S
PART.
HE TOUTED THIS AS SOME BIG NEVER
BEFORE SEEN THING THAT HE WAS
GOING TO DO.
IT DIDN'T COME OFF FOR HIM VERY
WELL.
I DON'T THINK
>> Laura: ONE MORE, JUST ONE
MORE.
THIS IS THE -- OH, ONE MORE.
THE POT, KETTLE, BLACK AWARD
GOES TO -- BETO OROURKE.
BETO MADE THIS SLANDEROUS CLAIM
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> RACISM AND VIOLENCE LONG BEEN
A PART OF AMERICA WAS WELCOMED
OUT IN THE OPEN AND DIRECTED TO
MY HOMETOWN IN EL PASO, TEXAS
WHERE 22 PEOPLE WERE KILLED,
DOZENS MORE GRIEVOUSLY INJURED
BY A MAN CARRYING A WEAPON HE
SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
BUY IN THE FIRST PLACE, INSPIRED
TO KILL BY OUR PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: FOLLOWING THAT, HE HAD
THE GALL TO SAY THIS.
>> THE BITTERNESS, THE
PETTINESS, THE SMALLNESS OF THE
MOMENT, THE INCENTIVES TO ATTACK
ONE ANOTHER AND TRY TO MAKE
DIFFERENCES WITHOUT
DISTINCTIONS, MOUNTAINS OUT OF
MOLE HILLS, WE HAVE TO BE
BIGGER.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, REAL
QUICK --
>> WE HAVE TO BE BIGGER.
YOU KNOW, IT'S AN OUTRAGE THAT
BETO WITHOUT ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT AND BLAME THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE SHOOTING.
>> Laura: DISGUSTING.
>> HE'S TRYING TO SCORE
POLITICAL POINTS.
HE'S GOING NOWHERE.
GOING NOWHERE.